und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend diplomatie bringt keine
ergebnisse ich habe keine leben mehr zu
verschenken das sagte der ukrainische
präsident des elends die kürzlich in
einem interview mit dem us-sender cbs
dass die ukrainische regierung auf
diplomatische gepflogenheiten keine
großen rücksichten mehr nimmt hat dann
heute der deutsche bundespräsident
erfahren einmal mehr muss man sagen
frank walter steinmeier war zuletzt
schon vom ukrainischen botschafter in
berlin attackiert worden doch heute geht
weit darüber hinaus steinmeier war zu
besuch in polen und wollte von dort
zusammen mit dem polnischen und den drei
baltischen präsidenten nach kiew reisen
sie lenski ließ jedoch wissen er sei
dort nicht willkommen
mein kollege und freund der polnische
staatspräsident an sehr gut hat in den
vergangenen tagen angeregt dass wir
beide gemeinsam mit den präsidenten
estland lettland und litauen eine reise
nach kiew unternehmen um dort ein
starkes zeichen gemeinsame europäische
solidarität mit der ukraine zu senden
und zu setzen ich war dazu bereit
aber offenbar und ich muss zur kenntnis
nehmen wahr dass in kiew nicht gewünscht
tja theo koll das ist ja doch ein
fachlich massiver diplomatischer affront
gegen ein staatsoberhaupt und gegen
steinmeier persönlich oder
absolut also ein zweifaches jahr auf die
frage die abweisung gilt einerseits der
person steinmeiers aber ist ja gar nicht
zu trennen von dessen amt als
staatsoberhaupt die person steinmeier
ist für die ukrainische politik vor
allem jahr der langjährige deutsche
außenminister dem zu enge beziehungen zu
russland vorgeworfen werden und der vor
kurzem selbst auch fehler in seiner
russlandpolitik zugegeben hat der
ukrainische botschafter hat die kritik
hier sehr offen formuliert steinmeier
habe ein spinnennetz der kontakte mit
russland geknüpft und das verhältnis zu
russland sagte botschafter sei für
steinmeier etwas heiliges gewesen diese
kritik aber und steinmeier wissen zu
lassen dass er in kiew ein unerwünschter
gast
sei das ist natürlich gleichzeitig auch
ein affront gegen das deutsche
staatsoberhaupt und damit eigentlich
gegen die bundesrepublik insgesamt der
polnische präsident du da jedenfalls hat
so höre ich heute die hände über dem
kopf zusammengeschlagen als er von der
ausladung steinmeiers hörte und meinte
das helfe doch am ende nur putin gibt es
dann reaktionen darauf in berlin
ja also berlin reagiert offiziell betont
cool ein regierungssprecher hat nur
knapp schriftlich erklärt deutschland
gehöre zu den entschiedensten
unterstützer und der ukraine und auch
der bundespräsident beziehe ja klar und
eindeutig stellung auf seiten der
ukraine der spd fraktionschef rolf
mützenich hat heute abend daran erinnert
dass deutschland die ukraine seit vielen
jahren wirtschaftlich und ja seit
kriegsbeginn auch humanitär und
militärisch unterstützt mein eindruck
ist dass kiew sich mit dieser aktion
politisch und auch emotional keinen
gefallen getan hat auch der dauer
kritische und fordernde ton des
ukrainischen botschaft das wird hier in
berlin zwar einerseits verstanden aber
um ehrlich zu sein auch zunehmend
genervt entgegengenommen so hatte er
sich am wochenende schon eher eine kiew
reise des kanzlers gewünscht die von
steinmeier sagte er habe nur
symbolischen charakter die einladungen
scholz hat er heute abend übrigens
erneuert aber um ehrlich zu sein mit
einer abweisung des bundespräsidenten
von heute dürfte eine kanzler reise
absehbar unwahrscheinlich werden das
gebietet auch schon der respekt vor dem
vierten staatsoberhaupt dankte für die
einschätzung andere europäische und auch
deutsche politiker hingegen reisen in
die ukraine und sind dort auch gekommen
so fuhren heute drei prominente
vertreter des deutschen bundestags in
den westen des landes die vorsitzenden
der parlamentsausschüsse für
verteidigung auswärtiges und europa
marie agnes strack zimmermann michael
roth und anton hofreiter ein dass sie
alle drei auf mehr tempo bei
waffenlieferungen pochen und damit nicht
immer in einklang mit dem
bundeskanzleramt stehen andreas künast
hat sie auf dieser reise begleiten
für diesen einsatz gehört blaulicht aufs
dach gehören splitterschutzwesten in den
kofferraum gehört schwarz-rot-gold
hinter die gepanzerte frontscheibe in
der polnischen grenzstadt gesellschaft
hat ein dutzend sicherheitsbeamter eine
reise vorbereitet von der sie eigentlich
abraten aber die abgeordneten hofreiter
brot und strack zimmermann haben sich
die genehmigungen erkämpft dieses
zeichen muss sein und es muss jetzt sein
die reise war selbstverständlich nicht
einfach zu organisieren
denn es ist ein kriegsgebiet auch wenn
wir nur im westen der ukraine unterwegs
sind und es ist einfach zentral um
solidarität zu zeigen und um sich ein
bild vor ort zu machen von jeff an die
grenze vom frieden in den krieg braucht
der deutsche konvoi eine
dreiviertelstunde deutschland ist spät
dran bei besuchen aber auch bei anderen
entscheidungen über sanktionen über
waffenlieferungen
am stau an der grenze darf die kolonne
vorbei einer der vorteile wenn man gast
des landes ist diplomatenpass anmeldung
willkommen in der ukraine
man muss auch ein paar signale setzen
dass man versucht auch anteil zu nehmen
und diese gesten der solidarität die
sollte man nicht unterschätzen aber noch
einmal das hat nicht ich zu entscheiden
und zu bewerten das haben unsere
ukrainischen partnerinnen und partner zu
entscheiden dass genau in diesen minuten
die ukrainischen partner entscheiden
dass sie vom bundespräsidenten kein
signal der solidarität wollen werden die
bundestags reisenden zunächst gar nicht
glauben aber in lemberg am sitz der
regionalregierung bekommen auch sie zu
spüren wie enttäuscht die ukraine von
deutschland ist kommen sie erst mal rein
hier ist es sicher
beim treffen mit abgeordneten der
werkhof ner radar des kieler parlaments
liegt nach wenigen minuten eine liste
auf dem tisch marder ausführung 1 mit
typenbezeichnung und foto die
parlamentskollegen aus der ukraine
argumentieren kenntnisreich aber auch
emotional
ich bitte sie von ganzem herzen nutzen
sie ihren einfluss danke
in ihren parteien gelten die drei
ausschussvorsitzenden als besonders
entschiedene unterstützer der ukraine
vor zwei tagen hat strack-zimmermann
ihre meinung geändert von gegen auf für
die lieferung schwerer waffen dass sie
an dem tag eingeladen sind an dem ihr
staatsoberhaupt ausgeladen wird muss
erst noch verarbeitet werden ja das ist
ein ungewöhnlicher vorgang und das
sollte man glaube ich in ruhe klären was
dahinter steckt das ist nicht freundlich
aber ich glaube dass die nerven überall
blank liegen und deswegen empfehle ich
in diesem fall hinter den kulissen mal
zu klären es muss noch einiges geklärt
werden diplomatisch militärisch
emotional hinter den kulissen und davor
wir brauchen waffen keine warmen worte
so sieht es die ukrainische regierung
schwere werfen sollen geliefert werden
möglichst viel möglichst schnell zumal
damit gerechnet wird dass die russen in
den nächsten tagen einen großangriff im
osten starten und ihnen im süden die
hafenstadt mario pohl endgültig in die
hände zu fallen droht was kann der
westen was kann deutschland liefern dazu
gleich fragen an ex nato general ramms
vorab wirft oracle einen kurzen blick
auf die waffen über die hierzulande
diskutiert wird sie beginnt ihren
bericht aber mit dem neuesten auftritt
von putin
für wladimir putin ist es eine ideale
kulisse und ein perfekter zeitpunkt
zusammen mit dem belarussischen
präsidenten lukaschenko besucht er heute
an der chinesischen grenze das kosmodrom
vor genau 61 jahren flog der russische
kosmonaut gagarin als erster mensch ins
weltall von hier lässt putin die welt
wissen er wird gewinnen
wir werden unsere ziele erreichen
derweil sammelt die russische armee
weiter kräfte für ihren grossangriff im
osten der ukraine
die ukrainische regierung fleht die welt
weiter an zu helfen mit waffen und einem
embargo
was mich am meisten besorgt ist dass die
entscheidungsprozesse in berlin so lange
dauern wer in berlin zeichnet hat hilfe
es nicht
was kiew will sind artillerie
raketenabwehrsysteme und panzer zum
beispiel den leopard oder martha
die firma rheinmetall ließ wissen man
könne den leopard 1 innerhalb von sechs
wochen liefern
während die außenministerin auf eine
schnelle lieferung drin bleibt es im
kanzleramt still auch die
verteidigungsministerin eher defensiv
erklärungsversuche ich bitte auch
nachzuvollziehen dass wir in bezug auf
die ankündigung von dem was wir liefern
von dem was wir leisten dass wir da sehr
sehr verschwiegen damit umgehen dass die
ukraine mit deutschen waffen und panzer
nicht um geben könne wurde von kiew
bereits mehrfach zurückgewiesen
wir wissen genau wie wir mit den waffen
und geräten umgehen müssen mit allen ob
mit flugabwehrraketen oder panzern das
ist kein geheimnis für uns
wir sind seit acht jahren darin geübt
weil wir an nato übungen teilgenommen
haben
[Musik]
in mario pohl im süden der ukraine geht
die offensive russischer truppen weiter
mehr als 10.000 tote soll es dort geben
eine geburtsklinik wurde evakuiert hier
in diesem bunker gibt es babys die noch
nie das tageslicht gesehen haben
wollen mit einem liter experten sprechen
mit egon ramms general ade des tieres
der bundeswehr und herr rams vereine der
höchsten nato generäle und nahm general
ramms
gute vorsorge die ukraine sagen wir
brauchen jetzt nicht nur defensivwaffen
wir brauchen jetzt waffen mit denen wir
auch angreifen und gebiete zurückerobern
können schweres gerät die habe ich das
als laie zu verstehen salopp gesagt mit
panzerfäusten kann man einen krieg nicht
gewinnen
mit panzerfäusten können wir das
erreichen was die ukrainische
streitkräfte in den letzten wochen
erreicht haben nämlich die russen
aufzuhalten und da wo die russen
vorgedrungen sind oder auch die
separatisten wie beispielsweise in mario
pohl können sie diese bereiche mit
panzerfäusten oder infanteriewaffen kaum
zurück erholen und die ukraine muss ein
interesse daran haben aber
beispielsweise mario mario pohl zu
entsetzen bei auch andere bereiche die
erobert worden sind auch im bereich der
separatisten gebiete wieder zurück zu
bekommen und daher ist die forderung
nach schweren waffen durchaus
nachvollziehbar schwere waffen das meint
vor allem auch panzer und da haben wir
eben im bericht auch gesehen da werden
auch konkrete forderungen auf den tisch
gelegt und es gibt angebote von der
deutschen rüstungsindustrie und heißt es
immer von bundeswehr seiten also nicht
von allen aber von so einigen aus dem
verteidigungsministerium das geht gar
nicht die ukraine müssen wir erstmal
lernen mit uns zu gehen die man so ein
marder oder einen leopard 1 eines dieser
ausgemusterten panzer fährt der bus der
ukrainische verteidigungsminister sagt
dass es nützt natürlich können wir das
wie schätzen sie das ein
es ist bedarf sicherlich eine
ausbildungs wohl am leopard 1 auf 5 also
vom schützenpanzer marder
möglicherweise auch artillerie waffen
die damit zu gehören könnten also
panzerhaubitzen raketenwerfer und
dergleichen die auch nach meinem
kenntnisstand mit auf der wunschliste
der ukraine stehen die frage ist wie
weit sich diese ausbildung aus denen
muss die ukraine haben eigentlich in den
letzten wochen unter beweis gestellt
dass sie relativ schnell mit neuen gerät
umgehen können auch wenn dieses schulter
gestützte waffen panzerfäuste und
fliegen fäuste waren so glaube ich
trotzdem dass sie sich in die bedienung
solcher waffen sehr schnell rein
arbeiten würden und wenn man sich dabei
entsprechend unterstützt kann man auch
erreichen dass sie auf einer kürzung
zeitachse als sie im augenblick in
deutschland diskutiert wird mit den
waffen entsprechend umgehen können ein
anderes argument ist die bundeswehr kann
jetzt gar keine mörder die sie aktuell
benutzt abgeben dann müsste sie die aus
litauen zurückziehen und dann könnte sie
ihren nato verpflichtungen nicht mehr
nachkommen etwas vereinfacht gesagt da
stände dann die bundeswehr irgendwann
blank da dass das ginge auch nicht so
schlimm um unser heer so sie wissen ja
sie wissen ja von der aussage des
inspekteurs des heeres und wenn sie mal
die bündnisverpflichtungen hinaus geht
dann stehen wir blank da es handelt sich
hierbei sowohl bei den leopard 15 als
auch bei den morden um waffen die in der
truppe nicht mehr im gebrauch sind weil
sie beispielsweise
durch den zulaufenden schützenpanzer
puma ersetzt werden und wenn die
industrie solche waffen auf dem hof
stehen hat dann sollte man sich mit
industrie zusammensetzt und sollte
kreative lösungen finden um auf diese
art und weise die ukraine zu
unterstützen vor slomka ich bin der
meinung die ukraine verteidigt die
europäische und auch die deutsche
freiheit in der ukraine von der als jede
unterstützung verdient da gibt es ja
auch durchaus generelle ex generäle die
da anderer meinung sind also zum
beispiel früheren militärberater von
frau merkel ihre fahrt brigadegeneral
sagten schwere waffen in die ukraine
liefern dass es sehr sehr riskant das
könnte den weg zu noch schlimmeren
eskalationen oder gar dritten weltkrieg
ebnen
also den dritten weltkrieg sehe ich
nicht eskalation sind natürlich möglich
weil keiner von uns sagen kann wie der
präsident putin auf diese dinge
reagieren wird aber wir wissen auch dass
aus der tschechei aus der tschechischen
republik
schützenpanzer und kampfpanzer geliefert
worden sind und dieses bisher ohne
reaktion geblieben von daher wir müssen
wir sehen wie wir der ukraine auf der
einen seite helfen können ohne die
eskalation schwelle zu einer direkten
auseinandersetzung zwischen nato und
russland zu überschreiten wir haben noch
eine kleine kurze frage zum schluss
putin hat ja offenbar seinen
oberbefehlshaber also sein top general
für den krieg in der ukraine
ausgetauscht man sie waren selbst
general ist das normal dass man mitten
im krieg gefährde wechselt auf dieser
ebene
also normalerweise bevor man einen krieg
beginnt hat man die generelle in die
entsprechenden positionen gesetzt zu
denen man entsprechend vertrauen hat wir
müssen aber jetzt sicherlich bilanzieren
wie der angriff bisher auf die ukraine
verlaufen ist und wenn wir den angriff
auf kiew sehen muss man ganz klar sagen
dieser ist gescheitert was ja auch zu
den umgruppierung geführt hat und
daraufhin hat putin möglicherweise für
den oberbefehlshaber diese operation das
vertrauen verloren interessanter
einschätzung eines hacks general ramms
vielen dank für das gespräch
ja na herzlichen dank
derweil kommen aus der ukraine immer
mehr berichte über gräueltaten der
russischen armee oder ihrer söldner in
gebieten aus denen sie wieder abgezogen
sind berichten frauen über
vergewaltigungen und erschießungen es
werden folteropfer massengräber und
leichen gefunden
und es werden beweise gesammelt
dazu passt dieses riesige plakat das am
rathaus der litauischen hauptstadt
vilnius packt eine botschaft an den
russischen präsidenten putin den haag
wartet auf dich den haag sitz des
internationalen
strafgerichtshofs tim krüger war heute
für uns sinn butscher jener inzwischen
auf so furchtbare weise berühmt
gewordenen stadt im großraum kiew
aufräumen in butter ob mit schwerem
gerät oder dem besen den menschen kann
es nicht schnell genug gehen die äußeren
zeichen der russischen angriffe der
besatzung zu beseitigen innerlich aber
bleiben die wunden valentina weil sie
lieben da hat alles miterlebt die
angriffe die toten auf der straße sie
nennt uns namen zeigt wo die menschen
erschossen lagen und beerdigt wurden
ich weine die ganze zeit ich weine nur
das ist alles weinen was soll ich nur
fühlen nach all dem es war doch so schön
hier
ob die wunden irgendwann heilen wird
auch von der aufarbeitung der
gräueltaten abhängen mord folter
vergewaltigung bomben auf zivilisten die
ermittlungen laufen bereits massengräber
werden geöffnet hunderte todesopfer aus
dem großraum kiel obduziert
jede leiche die bereits identifiziert
ist wird forensisch untersucht wie jene
die noch nicht identifiziert sind werden
wir dna tests durchführen
herauszufinden wer sie sind dann werden
wir die todesursache fest der erzählung
in hamburg und jeden tag werden weitere
leichen entdeckt
pressetermin mit der ukrainischen
generalstaatsanwälten heute in butter es
geht um tausende fälle mutmaßlicher
kriegsverbrechen mit hunderten
verdächtigen auf seiten des russischen
militärs und der russischen führung
wir sollten unsere fälle so aufbereiten
dass die ankläger der internationalen
gerichte unsere felle aufnehmen und
unsere beweise nutzen können nach den
standards internationalen humanitären
rechts
internationale ermittler helfen bei den
untersuchungen seit heute im einsatz in
der ukraine französische
ermittlungsbeamte
auch internationale
menschenrechtsorganisationen wie human
rights watch sichern beweise führen etwa
zeugen interviews durch es ist ein
rennen gegen die zeit
im moment kommen die entgegen denn die
vor einigen tagen zurück erobert wurden
als die russischen kräfte abgezogen sind
und in solchen gebieten gibt es
potenziell viele wertvolle beweise für
mögliche verbrechen aber diese
verschwinden mit jeder minute die
vergeht
ob allerdings die mutmaßlichen täter
jemals vor gericht stehen und für die
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden können ist
völlig unklar
und jetzt erstmal andere nachrichten des
tages von heinz voit
außenministerin berbalk ist seit heute
in mali wo im rahmen von internationalen
missionen auch die bundeswehr im einsatz
ist die aktuellen bundestagsmandat für
die deutsche beteiligung laufen ende mai
aus beim besuch des
bundeswehr-kontingents ingo wollte sich
werburg vor ort ein bild machen über
einen einsatz unter schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen an der un mission zur
stabilisierung des von islamistischem
terrorismus bedrohten landes sind
derzeit rund 1000 deutsche soldaten
beteiligt
nach dem rücktritt von
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel haben
sich die grünen auf ihrer
vorstandsklausur in schleswig holstein
noch nicht auf eine nachfolgerin
festgelegt feststehen soll nach worten
von co-chefin ricarda lang bisher nur
dass wieder eine frau das amt übernehmen
soll der vorstand der partei wolle
zeitnah einen entsprechenden vorschlag
machen
in der sogenannten party gate affäre
verhängt die londoner polizei ein
strafgeld gegen den britischen
premierminister johnson es geht offenbar
um die feier in johnsons büro zu seinem
geburtstag am 19 juni 2020 johnson
erklärte er habe das strafgeld bezahlt
und bat um entschuldigung
in new york im stadtteil brooklyn hat
ein unbekannter in der u-bahn zehn
menschen durch schüsse verletzt nach
bisherigen ermittlungen hat der mann in
einer u-bahn die in eine station einfuhr
eine gasmaske aufgesetzt und einem
behälter geöffnet aus dem rauch in den
waggon strömte dann schoss er und
verletzte menschen im zug und auf dem
bahnsteig der täter ist auf der flucht
hintergründe sind unklar
wir kommen noch mal zurück zum thema
krieg in der ukraine und den folgen für
deutschland welche auswirkungen ein
vollständiges energie embargo gegen
russland auf die deutsche wirtschaft
haben würde ist ja unter ökonomen
umstritten
einigkeit herrscht aber darüber dass wir
uns so schnell wie möglich vom
russischen erdgas unabhängig machen
müssen und das dauerhaft auf dem weg
dahin werde aber manche kröte zu
schlucken seien waren fachleute ideale
lösungen mit denen auch umweltschützer
glücklich sind werde es kurzfristig
nicht geben elisabeth schmidt berichtet
wie sich niedersachsen jetzt auf die
errichtung von flüssiggasterminals
einrichtung so sieht er aus der
niedersächsische gas turbo ein karton
mit 7000 seiten die
genehmigungsunterlagen für das
flüssigerdgas terminal in stade sie sind
eingereicht keiner der anderen geplanten
lng standorte ist bislang so weit
gekommen
warum weil wir auch den druck haben ich
finde es erschreckend dass es sozusagen
so weit kommen musste dass dieser krieg
in der ukraine und die die
unabhängigkeit die wir herstellen wollen
dazu führt dass wir schneller werden
beim ausbau der infrastruktur der
politische wille will und so sollen
tanker hier bereits 2024 zwei jahre
früher als bislang geplant flüssiggas an
land bringen in der aktuellen energie
krise kommt das terminal in stade
dennoch zu spät jetzt rächt sich dass
deutschland anders als seine
europäischen nachbarn bislang vollauf
russisches pipeline gas gesetzt hat wenn
sie abhängig sind von pipelines dann
können haben sie in einer politischen
krise keine alternativ möglichkeit
schnell flüssiggas zu importieren
wenn sie aber ein flüssiggasterminal
haben und es gibt probleme in einem
lieferland dann können sie den tanker
irgendwo in ein anderes land schicken
des lng terminals in deutschland
errichtet sind könnten diese
spezialschiffe eine übergangslösung sein
sie wandeln flüssiges lng wieder in gas
um sind mobil und mietbar eines davon
soll bereits zum jahreswechsel in
wilhelmshaven fest machen und ein
fünftel des russischen gases ersetzen
was bislang fehlt eine 28 kilometer
lange gasleitung die lng anleger und
gasspeicher verbindet eine firma bekommt
nun acht monate zeit für ihren augen
unserer eigentümer haben letzte woche
die finale investitionsentscheidung
getroffen so dass wir bereits jetzt in
dieser phase wo wir noch keine
genehmigungen haben rohre bestellt haben
engagieren planen im turbotempo ohne
genehmigung es ist dass tesla prinzip
doch ärger scheint auch in wilhelmshaven
programmiert denn die gasleitung soll
durch wohn und naturschutzgebiete führen
diese flüssig crosstrainer sind unter
störfall betriebe das sind gefährliche
betriebe die müssen ordentlich genehmigt
werden und da kann man nicht einfach die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
überspringen ob und wie viele klagen
kommen werden unklar viel
überzeugungsarbeit wird nötig sein und
viel steuergeld 200 millionen euro sind
für die terminals stade und
wilhelmshaven eingeplant 250 millionen
für brunsbüttel wir müssen uns einfach
vergegenwärtigen dass
versorgungssicherheit auch immer etwas
kostet es ist ein öffentliches gut und
kann aus meiner sicht oder konnte aus
meiner sicht auch niemals alleine der
industrie oder den globalen märkten
überlassen werden gas statt grünes
gewissen der krieg in der ukraine zwingt
deutschland zum handeln langfristig soll
sich aber auch das terminal in stade in
richtung mehr klimaschutz bewegen statt
fossilem lng soll dann grüner
wasserstoff importiert werden
krieg und hohen ergie preise tragen
natürlich auch zur inflation bei und mit
dem thema geht es jetzt bereits weiter
die inflation hat deutlich angezogen die
usa und deutschland melden heute für
märz inflationsraten so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht 7,3 prozent betrug sie
hierzulande im jahresvergleich laut
statistischem bundesamt stefanie bareth
in welchen bereichen sind die preise
besonders stark gestiegen verbraucher
müssen tatsächlich für fast alles tiefer
in die tasche greifen ob beim tanken
heizen oder im supermarkt spitzenreiter
nach wie vor die energiekosten sie
bleiben angeheizt durch den ukraine
krieg preistreiber nummer eins so ist
heizöl inzwischen mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie im vorjahr dieselkraftstoff
liegt um über 60 prozent zu und gas
verteuert sich um 42 die stromkosten
steigen um 18 prozent auch für
lebensmittel müssen verbraucher mehr
ausgeben speisefette durch den ukraine
krieg knapper verteuerten sich um 17
prozent frisches gemüse umfasst 15
butter um 18 und tiefkühlobst um gut 22
prozent dabei scheint das ende der
preisspirale noch nicht erreicht denn
auch deutsche großhändler meldeten heute
rekordverdächtige preiserhöhungen von 23
prozent weil rohstoffe und vorprodukte
knapper sind der großhandel gilt ja so
als scharnier zwischen herstellern und
endkunden höhere kosten landen gern
verzögert bei verbrauchern immer weiter
entfernt sich damit die inflationsrate
vom zielkorridor 2 prozent den die
europäische zentralbank als ideal für
preisstabilität und konjunktur ansieht
in den usa hat die inflation heute die
marke von acht prozent geknackt dort
steuert die us notenbank aber längst mit
entschiedenen zinsschritten dagegen der
druck auf die ezb am donnerstag ein
signal auszusenden erwächst doch wenn
die welt vielen dank
die dfb-frauen haben die vorzeitige
qualifikation für die wm 2003 und 20
verpasst das deutsche frauen
nationalteam verlor 2 zu 3 gegen die
mannschaft serbien dennoch bleibt
deutschland in der gruppe im moment auf
platz eins
der schauspieler und schriftsteller
michael degen ist tot er starb nach
angaben des rowohlt verlags am samstag
im alter von 90 jahren in hamburg sie
sind dabei sehr liebte her so kannten
ihn millionen doktor martin sanders in
diese drombuschs eine seiner
bekanntesten und zugleich seine
paraderolle graumelierter gentleman
attraktiv publikumsliebling
seine eigene leidenschaft gilt erst dem
theater faust hamlet rund 40 jahre
spielt michael degen die großen helden
ab mitte der achtziger traumschiff und
kollegen geht in serie und wendet sich
der tv kamera zu
ein leichtes spiel hier schwer war das
wirkliche leben des gebürtigen
chemnitzers michaels jüdische familie
wird von den nazis verfolgt der vater im
kz ermordet seine mutter und er
überleben in einem versteck niemals
darüber reden das musste er seiner
mutter versprechen sagte jetzt wollen
wir ganz normale menschen sein und
dazu war es wirklich nötig dass man
verdrängte glaubt ich glaube es war
nicht richtig heute mit 67 bricht er das
schweigen schreibt biographien und setzt
sich auch als schauspieler mit der shoah
auseinander für seine rolle als
holocaust überlebender in soko leipzig
bekommt er einen fernsehpreis
von einer familie geblieben ist
michael degen ein leben für das
schauspiel und für die erinnerung
das wasser uns an diesem dienstagabend
gleich folgt das neue zdf format don't
stop the music an einer berliner
grundschule begleitet bülent ceylan 50
kinder die erstmals die magie des
musizierens erleben gibt sehr ans herz
und ist zugleich ein wissenschaftliches
projekt große ein schaltempfehlung oder
0 15 gibt es dann unser heute schneit
update mit gundula gause und uns morgen
wieder wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der märz war nicht nur in
deutschland zu trocken sondern in teilen
europas in rot dargestellt sind die
gebiete wo es 20 prozent und weniger
regen gehabt im gesamten monat es war
durchaus richtung polen der fall und
auch richtung skandinavien generell in
europa war es viel zu trocken wie man
hier an den farben erkennen kann ja
eigentlich im südwesten europas richtung
spanien war sogar zu nass da war die
meiste zeit tiefer luftdruck ansonsten
die meiste zeit bei uns aber hoher
luftdruck wir schauen auf das aktuelle
wetter und da haben wir es zwar noch mit
hohem luftdruck zu tun das wird aber
gestört von diesem tief über den
britischen inseln und dieses tief wird
uns erreichen morgen am nachmittag wird
schauer und gewitter auslösen dabei
kommt auch warme luft und saharastaub
mit in der nacht gibt es wenige wolken
im osten deutschlands sonst sind
schleierwolken unterwegs sarah staub
kann schon dabei sein und temperaturen
sinken auf null gerade im osten und 10
grad ganz im westen es ist eine deutlich
mildere nacht als die nacht zuvor morgan
tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein aber zum
nachmittag dann schauer und gewitter die
vor allem dann richtung nordosten ziehen
sonst kann es eben auch wieder
saharastaub geben und der trügt ein
wenig den himmel temperaturen erreichen
15 bis 16 grad an der nordsee sonst
werte um die 20 grad marke 24 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und am oberrhein die
nächsten tage am donnerstag schauer und
gewitter die durchziehen bei 12 bis 22
grad und ab karfreitag ist es im norden
kühler ein schöner abend